I was surfing on the West Side we've got
four other people and we heard the
lifeguards Sirens going off making
announcement and then the beach got
cleared from either side and she knew
something had gone on the helicopters
come in so you're serious
um of course you saw someone so you can
see if you're here the lifeguards put
off a screen so no one can see but
unfortunately from where we were we
couldn't and then the jet skis would go
around the pier looking for stuff
um so me and three other Surfers a lot
to help we actually added into the here
let's have a look basically there were
two people missing at the time and then
after about half hour they said uh
everyone was accounted for and then we
just we carried on